A lot's happened in the last ten years.
It's a miracle I'm even sitting here now.
I got a second chance.
I'm going to take advantage of that.
But I need you with me, Pete.
You're going to heal the world.
Guys, this is my best friend, Harry.
Hey, good to meet you.
Job, huh?
Just even have time for tutoring.
Figure it out.
I didn't know
there were bears in these woods,
M.J..
I have another name for you.
Kraven.
I was here on some kind of hot.
No. If you need me, I'm just a call away.
You don't know what you do for me.
Oh. Miles talks about his how to be
a better Spider-Man, how to help you.
The hell is going on with me?
He's not himself. Go help him.
This was our dream.
I'm not going to sit.
We're going to kill you.
Miles, I need your help.
What is this stuff?
Wait.
Pete, I got an idea.
Nice.
One more time. Three.
One, two.
Right.
Welcome back, everyone.
Happy Comic-Con Week.
Marvel just dropped a brand new Spider-Man
two trailer for the video game.
There's a bunch of Easter eggs
here. We'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
when the game is released in October,
I'll probably give a couple of copies
of the actual game away.
It'll be coming out around the same time.
Big coincidence here as the Kraven
the Hunter movie is coming out.
Kraven is going to be one of the
main villains in this game.
That is what we call synergy.
But obviously the biggest metaphorical
and literal thing in this trailer is way
more venom.
Tony Todd was actually
at their Comic-Con panel
and did some more of the Venom voice.
We offer them.
lot of stuff going on here.
So would you start at the beginning
of the trailer
and work our way through shot by shot,
talking about Easter eggs, WTF moments.
There is a ton of brand new footage
though.
they start with a brand new scene of Harry
Osborn looking like after he's gotten
he'll talk he's come out of the tank
and he's talking to Peter at Midtown High
about the past ten years of their life
together
his whole speech about not taking things
for granted and wanting to heal
the world is meant to dovetail
with the end of the trailer in the venom
voice We will heal the world, as in Harry
Osborn venom.
and I think they're pretty clearly
implying from the previous trailer scenes
all this heal the world stuff
is that the venom symbiote
wants to consume the entire planet
like turn the entire planet
into a planet of Symbiotes
there were a lot of posts a while ago
when they released the last big trailer
saying the Harry Osborn wouldn't
be venom during the game.
But I think they were referring
to all the footage
that they dropped of Peter Parker
wearing the symbiote.
that's like a whole separate thing
because there are several different scenes
in this trailer where you see
a couple of different versions
of the character, like you see
Full on Venom with the Spider-Man symbol.
But then you also see
Peter Parker
wearing the symbiote, in the idea
is they're meant to be two completely
separate characters.
So I think that venom does wind up
being Harry Osborn.
You're going to heal the world.
We're going to kill you.
Wales with Harry
Osborn in Venom have said the same thing
in different parts of the trailer.
We see Miles Morales and Peter Parker
going on a mission together.
We saw a lot of them
in the last big trailers.
We know a big part of the game
will be them together on missions.
Then they go to Coney Island.
They're bunch of Spider-Man
Easter eggs in the background here, too.
Like you have hydro four hydro man.
And this person in the back
is wearing a T-shirt
with the Spider-Man
symbol made like a heart.
Peter introduces
Harry Osborn to everyone else.
When Miles says, Are you sure
you're going to have time for tutoring?
It just means that Peter
has become a teacher.
In the time since the last game
I think the person with the green T-shirt
in the background with the green glowing
logo is meant to evoke Green Goblin
like they might have
some Green Goblin references in the game,
but I'm not expecting him
to be a huge character.
Maybe in the third game though,
they play some footage
from the last trailer
hyping up more of the Kraven threat.
this bill and he faces with the bear
costume is called a grizzly.
His real name is Maxwell Markham.
he was a wrestler turned supervillain
due to his legacy being stripped from him
after an accusation of fraud and to this
day still seeks revenge on the people.
He thinks wronged him.
when he tells MJ about Kraven,
it seems like
during the events of the game
she'll be working for Jonah Jamison.
At least they said that on the panel.
There's not a lot of footage of Jonah
Jameson during this trailer,
but she will be working for him
at some point.
it looks like at some point
the venom symbiote winds up healing Harry,
but then escapes in some disaster.
And then maybe that's
how it gets to Spider-Man.
this footage of Miles Morales confronting
this prisoner here is meant to be
Martin Lee, Mr. Negative.
He's confronting him
for killing his father.
that's what he means when you don't
realize what you took from me, then
they hype up the whole Spider-Man symbiote
storyline of it all with everybody.
Like all of his friends.
MJ Even Miles seem
like they get really worried about Peter,
and he goes super dark
because of the influence of the symbiote
this seems like mild
trying to infiltrate Kraven
The Hunter is based in all of his cohorts
coming for him.
Peter Parker with the Venom symbiote
trying to help the Lizard.
Kurt Connors.
I think one of the big storylines
in the last trailer was him trying to find
a serum to help cure Lizard before
everybody else got to him and killed him.
part of the idea, though, is that
because he's become a lizard,
he goes a little crazy.
So he's trying to stop him and cure him
before he ends up doing
something that gets himself killed.
there's more.
Norman Osborn, Harry Osborn scenes
inside the special lab where they had
the Venom symbiote
and he was in stasis trying to be healed.
Notice other days in the green light green
for Green Goblin more references there
when he gets really pissed off though,
it just seems like something
drives him to a darker place
and that maybe has something to do
with the Venom symbiote.
then we get full on venom.
I'm going crazy on one of Craven's ships.
And like I said, I think this is
a completely separate character.
Harry Osborn Venom,
not Peter Parker in the Venom symbiote
let me know in the comments.
Do you think this is actually
Harry Osborn venom or is it
another character who has become venom
Kraven,
the Hunter is going to be the main villain
and he comes to New York City
to start his great hunt,
like he comes for his hunting grounds
because there just way
more heroes and villains, anti-heroes
for him to take down.
the events of the game
are meant to pick up
after the events of the Spider-Man
Miles Morales game.
And obviously a couple of years
after the events of the first game.
But what they don't explain
is that when they pick up six months later
in New York City, Peter Parker already
has the Venom symbiote suit.
So you're wondering what happened to Harry
Osborn, who had the Venom symbiote
before him?
Norman Osborn will be Green Goblin
at some point, either during this game
or they'll tease him at the end
for Spider-Man three,
because they'll probably be a third game.
pretty easy to assume
They'll probably explain that
in some flashback
because it sounds like
you'll start the game
in that six months later timeline
where he already has the symbiote.
Or maybe there'll be some quick moment
at the beginning
where it explains
how he gets the symbiote.
well, when Kraven is selecting
New York City as his hunting grounds
and he looks at the pad,
they reveal most of the other characters
that are going to appear
now there's other characters
that they don't reveal.
Like Dinky is a big character
and he's not on the read out here.
but at least the other ones
that they show in this moment are black.
Cat Prowler, Wraith Tombstone
taskmaster kingpin.
Meaning he's coming back.
They locked him up at the beginning
of the first game. Shocker.
Then obviously the lizard in
when the action picks up six months
later in Queens, it looks like
what's happening is Spider man's house.
They come looking for Curt Connors lizard
who's broken out of his house
and run to the docks, with Spider-Man
busting out of his basement with the
symbiote on coming after Craven's people
yelling at them to stay off of him.
And you can see he's gone super aggro
which Miles Morales remarks on later
like no he's never like that in that's
meant to be right out of the comics
and you've seen Spider-Man
three with Tobey Maguire
you've seen all the other
symbiote stories.
It drives them way
darker, way more hardcore.
but the whole idea is that
he's trying to protect Curt Connors lizard
because it sounds like he's dying.
He says that he's dying,
and we're the only ones that can save him.
But also, in addition to that,
Craven has selected him to kill him
as one of his next targets.
when he calls Miles you notice that he's
using the drone, which looks like it's
based on vulture tech, like it's a vulture
looking type of drone.
But Jenkins
voice is speaking through it day.
The big thing too,
is that Spider-Man across the Spider-Verse
a lot of the pieces for Spider-Man
and characters are characters
during that movie,
like because it's a big multiverse movie.
they canonized both Spider-Man
for like this version of Spider-Man
and this version of Miles Morales,
as well as Spider Cat two.
The events of that movie.
you know, the thing they don't
really touch on here is the idea.
The RAF just holds
a lot of Spider-Man's villains,
so they might travel back there
at some point.
But it sounds like based
on all the targets that Kraven selects,
a bunch of them are already roaming
free around New York City.
they also released this extra little
trailer for the special Ps5 console.
They're releasing for the game
there'll be a bunch of other big trailers
dropping in the next couple of days.
There's
supposed to be a new Marvel's trailer
and there's supposed to be a Loki Season
two trailer.
I don't know if they delayed that
just because Marvel
changed all their Comic-Con plans,
but there's will be a bunch of other
big trailers
There should be an invincible Season
2 trailer on Friday.
Of course,
they'll do videos for everything.
Make sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss anything.
Click here for all my Comic-Con trailers.
I think the link, as soon as I start
posting those and click here for that.
Spider-Man Beyond the Spider-Verse Teaser
Trailer Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!